[Music]
- I'm a little knocked out by this news
I have to say oh the Stanley yeah I mean
it's just I literally as I was coming
here that's the first thing I saw I am I
was just having the conversation there's
not I I was just having the conversation
with other people in the other room and
I was saying that it is very rare for an
individual to have impacted the world
the way that Stan did and one can only
hope to live to be 95 I mean of course
and that's the fear you know sometimes
like when and there's a few people that
are close to my heart like actors that
have you know directors and people who
I've always been inspired by or getting
up there and that's the fear I always
have is that you know you're gonna get
this headline eventually you know but
but he was I mean I was just fortunate
to meet him and then I feel that I'm
just grateful that he was around to see
what Marvel was able to do completely
especially in the last 10 years and then
I feel like he always and then he had
the cameos you know and then I think he
was happy with the turnout yeah I know
completely I would we were just talking
about that as well about the fact that
who gets to see what like the last 10
years he has seen the world embrace
these matters I mean in such a big way
and and come to life and you know it
just be interesting I only I only met
him a few times I mean I never really
got like a full one-on-one with him you
know but he was always like but remember
Bucky's one of the good ones he's a good
guy
oh I definitely bring up that this
Disney streaming service I mean yeah
I've heard about it does know Plus
sounds like it's gonna be amazing and
Feige is doing the whole marble thing
with uh I guess low Tom Hiddleston's
gonna have his own series like a six
episode that's what that's what is being
said yes so there's a lot of talk that
your character could also be going that
route and getting a series have you can
you can can you comment on that and what
is your take on this the Disney
streaming thing I I don't know I mean I
think it's amazing you know I listen I
mean I I think
what we're seeing in television now in
terms of like character development I
mean that you know the shows like true
detective and Game of Thrones and how
they have the crown and and like what
they've done with characters and
storytelling is incredible so the so I
could see why you know they wouldn't
want to maybe do that because it gives
so much opportunity to enrich these
characters and and obviously an
opportunity like that would be you know
fantastic but I don't you know where
they're gonna take that you know it's I
never know you know this is never I'm
never told right or if you're told
you're not allowed to say yeah but we
you know we've we've talked about that
before like you know we've been in that
situation where it's like if you you
you've known if I knew something I would
you know like it kind of like maybe like
yeah you know but it's uh I I honestly
think it's just too early to tell at
this point I mean there's so much
storytelling that has yet to be shown to
people I mean you start out another
movie coming out which is my follow up
with drama so it's like what's gonna
happen Joe Russo recently said that the
cut they currently have is three hours
I have no doubts I mean the fact that
they were able to squeeze the last one
in two and a half hours it's kind of
impressive to me I think though it's
like how do you gonna how you're gonna
do that
right so the first the one you made part
three infinity war I guess no one really
had the full script everyone has like
old versions yeah but then again
remember like you know I shot the when I
was shooting anything nobody was ever
telling me what was part 1 or part 2 so
the truth is I don't even know if I'm in
this film because I what I've shot you
know was in part one you know so
anything that I shot may or may not have
been in part 1 or part 2 but I still
don't know right like there were things
we shot that we're never gonna make it
because it was easier to just convolute
the whole thing so it's like it's great
way you go alright well that's cool but
you know you you you know it's gonna you
know it's gonna deliver on a level that
you know we probably haven't even
digested yet because that's what they do
best
you